als ob gott ach du die ganze welt neigt
sich zur seite man als wir das fucking
inception guck dir das da hinten
das kitz und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video heute mal wieder
gaming nachdem gestern die shader
vorstellung kam ja wir sind wir haben
ein schöner drin aber das ist nicht der
täter mit der beute spiel werden denn
wir haben heute gewissermaßen eine
challenge oder einfach
eigentlich ist es eine herausforderung
zu gucken ob man überhaupt überlebt und
zwar habe ich mir hier in the waves
shader installiert heute dass wir eine
ganze runde mit max dj federspiel gott
dass die blöcke werden verschwunden
wegen dem jetzt schon
also hier darf man nicht anfällig für
die krankheit sein leute ich bin mal
gespannt wer es schafft sich das video
bis zum ende durch zuschauer nicht wenn
am ende wieder irgend geheimnis codewort
ein so dass alle die sich das angeschaut
haben sie kommentar schreiben könnte
das nimmt ein wirklich mit 88 eine
abschlüsse ist wenn du erst einmal muss
sich daher leider
man muss sich wirklich bewegen dann geht
es halbwegs aber immer noch man kann
auch vor gott mir ständig ich höre dir
ich leider kein müssten inzwischen
vollkommen richtig schlimm dass die
ganze runde lang durchzuziehen auch beim
pvp später in das match wird richtig
übel man ich kann auch nur die sprünge
habe ich als zuschauer das überhaupt so
lange schaffen so weit was man nicht so
weit weil ich ja noch richtig 33 junge
was ist das wird dir von oder schlecht
als wird den kranken
kamerafahrten im kino schlecht nicht
wirklich aber es ist ein mega komisches
gefühl im bauch
es gibt ja echt leute dafür anfällig
sind für gehört letzten berg da wollte
ich hoffe wenn euch übel wird dann
bricht den scheiß ab und schaut das
wieder nicht zu ende
niemand soll wegen ein video von mir
übel werden das ist es nicht wert ist es
einfach ein weiteres video von sydney
ich meine klar ist es nass aber es ist
auch einfach wisst ihr es gibt diesen
orten versteckt dass einem die
geschwindigkeit 99 euro du hast du das
einfach die ganze zeit über das ist
einfach dauern aber noch viel übler
weiter bewegen sich die blöcke nicht so
gut in der box
wildes sicht fällt mir schon kannst du
das anschauen und nicht so wirklich
leute ich irgendwann irgendwie mein kopf
tut weh aber dafür schlagen uns jetzt
ein paar rechner haben nicht schlecht
nach 1 729 - 23 419 addiert 38 28 können
die blöcke schon so hart verschoben sein
dass du einfach nicht schecks so dass du
einfach fall springt ja wie in der mitte
geht es halbwegs bewegen sie auch nach
links nach rechts aber ich weiß wenn ich
solch einer hinspiel wurde sich
hinbiegen oder oder wie oder was achtung
scheiße leute er kommt auf die idee so
ein schöner zu entwerfen
ich vertraue ich konzentriere mich voll
aufs gameplay und so kann ich mich
halbwegs sie durch retten
aber ich glaube als zuschauer ist das
mega heftig es ist schlimm wenn man
immer auf den nächsten block schoko
gleichen spiel
wieso reicht er nicht auch nicht ob man
diese reicht das nicht ich schwöre ich
spring doch voll weit hinten ich bin
jetzt mit zumindest ein alter hut
ach du scheiße findet ihr das nice ein
bisschen ich bin zu mir ist so geil ich
bin sogar dieses modul macht sie fertig
jawohl
jawoll alter jetzt hamas hamas
doch jetzt ich glaube die frage ist
nicht wer nicht gekürzt bei diesem video
das ist wichtig
das ist eine internet ist es eigentlich
nicht 632 88 alles klar
die kaufen wollte
unser einfluss dieser 1 mississippi
ich würde ja wenn ich danach nicht auf
stehe ich habe gerade erst richtig viel
gegessen leute ihr müsst euch mal in
meine lage versetzen ich habe gerade
eben ungelogen richtig viel gegessen und
jetzt das schoko muffins zum beispiel
gerade eben die luft ich glaub ich nicht
essen doch die die ungarn schon ja ich
hab nur ein gegessen wir noch ein
gewissen nein ich hab alle drei
aufgegessen scheiße ernst nein ich hab
dann überlassen alte architekt mich
einfach gleich locker leute so zynisch
dabei seien gar keinen bock und auch
meine mappe zweck wolltest einem zug
mitnehmen
am markt wird welchem zug am horizont
muss klein kurz kann man es kurz mal
erwartet stehen zwei alte leute
schwerer seegang würde sagen wenn es
noch so variieren würde und dann
irgendwie die sturmflut reinrutscht
alter rezeptur verwendet die sturmflut
na weil die weiße stadt ohne fred nein
warum komme ich an den blogger du bist
du crime ist oder dummies weder noch
wenn man nicht wenn es er hat immer noch
eine weile
ich könnte jetzt meine sein theoretisch
aber ich glaube nicht ich bin nie komax
ist schwer das modul das modul ist auch
mitglied an sich schon ordentlich also
das aber hat man was man noch dazu sagen
hat befindet oder nicht fähig die zeit
abgelaufen wird jetzt einfach gerade die
ganze brandzeit überstanden
wenn er mich jetzt hier noch sprechen
hört ihr seid great ape review jetzt
gott ach du die ganze welt neigt sich
zur seite man als wäre das fucking
inception die jungs ist das nicht toll
gemacht
also ich erwarte von niemandem dass er
sich dass sie bis zum ende an schaut
heute wurde ich einfach ein eimer oder
sowas
ohne jetzt aber guck dir das dahinter
ach du du nimmst du jetzt noch im
fenstermodus aufstand wurde das dank
nehme ich hier nicht in den
vollbildmodus auf sondern ein fenster so
dembek hat ein bisschen ekliges geben
muss ich sagen mir gar nicht gefallen ob
jetzt kann ich nachher sehr probieren
die ich etwas mitzuteilen so wie früher
wenn er mal auf dem gameboy gespielt
haben wirklich gemacht zwar optisch
werde ab gerade probiert bis zum
mitgestalter was gehen hier waren kinder
macht glaube ich wieder habe ich ja ich
habe ein kind gemacht habt ihr ja ok
erstmal erstmal verdrücken hier beine
vertreten
kommt einer allerdings schon mal kurz
die welt an hier ist einfach kurz an
der gleiche spieler vor der kanzlerin
von geschicken turnaround sehr schön ist
sagt max ich weiß es sehr zu schätzen
dass mir ist in dieser sache ja aber ich
machte kills leute ich mache die kills
das läuft ich glaube mein selbst das
ding spielt ist es nicht so schlimm aber
wenn man es das anschaut arbeiten du
nein ich muss den käse schneiden leute
vielleicht schneide ich dass wir heute
einfach nicht nehmen es mir nicht übel
vom fressen schwert dresden schwer hält
auch nur noch ein leben so wir müssen
uns endlich mal holt noch zwei das ganz
gut
wer ganz nah ist es hinter uns als ich
sie erst mal kein osze werde es wieder
hell wie ich weiß nicht was ich erwarte
deshalb längst voll korrekt oder ist
nicht voll gedeckt ach du scheiße
kannst du auch mal etwas was soll ich
sonst machen wenn ich es in den texten
können ja auch noch stimmt auch kommt
haben neben ok es dann habe ich weiter
für diesen baum nein ich hab keine
pfeile ich hab noch komplex und apple
auf hoher see die mitschrift aufstände
erschüttert auf dem schiff den ist aber
sie geht es da oder seiner ein matrose
er wurde das schiff am letzten pass der
geständige nicht schneller alles cool
rides weitermachen nein ich bin fit
machen
ich geh ja ich habe zwei eisen da kann
sie auch keine feinde machen ja wieder
feine noch augen stick nehmen müssen
das ist mein letzter gegner
wir wollen uns jetzt nicht über die
maßen beschleunigen
das wird echt schlimm also leute
codewort ist micro max los für alle die
sich bisher in angeschaut haben ihr seid
echt tapfer sorge das antun musste ich
wollte ausprobieren aber danke anfällig
max fürst dabei sein dann kann mich
erwachsen war dort haben leute okay das
was wir drei macht gut und pc